es justamente lo que han venido
reclamando la población rural del
interior del país y también la mayoría
de ciudadanos que haya una protección
por parte del estado a lo que es la
producción la venta de productos la
economía aunque la constitución de 1993
diversos observadores sociales han dicho
que ha estado privilegiando a grupos de
poder a empresarios en diversos sectores
del país y estos diversos observadores
sociales han dicho que ha ido en
desmedro de lo que es los bolsillos de
los ciudadanos del peruano de a pie
mejor dicho entonces pedro castillo
trata de recuperar los derechos de la
ciudadanía de la población recordemos
que él es un maestro rural y es
justamente la población al interior del
país donde no hay carreteras no existen
servicios de salud donde tienen mayores
problemas entonces él está tratando de
corregir lo que a su juicio denomina una
injusticia
es por eso que también él ha propuesto
la recuperación de los recursos
naturales y también lo que se denomina
la explotación de los recursos de un
linde de dineros energéticos petroleros
que va a necesitar una supervisión y
mayor participación del estado castillo
ha dicho que ahora va a tener que ser un
estado
socio de la empresa privada donde en el
estado peruano va a tener que tener
mayor presencia y participación y toda
la producción que mejor dicho la riqueza
que se genere va a tener que beneficiar
a la población local regional es
justamente eso ha sido lo que él ha
esposado como una de las principales
razones para modificar la constitución
peruana
esto no ha sido del agrado de la mayoría
de los congresistas porque solamente un
sector de los legisladores aplaudió
cuando era acaba de hacer estos anuncios
otro anuncio importante que ha hecho
pero casi va en el tema de la educación
es que se va a establecer el ingreso
directo a las universidades y ha sido
muy criticado en este país que los
estudiantes quienes han venido
recibiendo una ayuda de una educación no
del todo 100% perfecta han tenido que
pasar por rigurosos exámenes de admisión
de las universidades y precisamente son
las universidades particulares la que
más han lucrado con estos exámenes de
admisión que también ha sido duramente
criticado desde hace mucho tiempo por
colectivos que ven los derechos de los
ciudadanos entonces él va a permitir que
los
estudiantes que egresen de la secundaria
tengan un ingreso directo a los centros
de educación superior y también ha
señalado que aquellos jóvenes que no
estudian ni trabajan- pasen a formar
parte del servicio militar obligatorio
esto es mayor medida los primeros
lineamientos de lo que va a ser este su
siguiente
el gobierno que va a ser de cinco años
que se inicia el día de hoy y va a
tratar de tender puentes con los
partidos políticos que los puedan ayudar
a gobernar
lógicamente acá va a tener una situación
muy dura porque la mayoría del congreso
está siendo controlado por la derecha
hay una coalición de partidos políticos
que son muy cercanos ideales el cofuc y
moore y desde ya ellos han adelantado
que no van a tratar de darle pase con
las reformas y diversos analistas han
venido señalando que pedro castillo al
tener una bancada de 37 congresistas es
vulnerable a cualquier tipo de boicot o
bloqueo por parte de las otras bancadas
que en su mayoría tienen el control del
parlamento y hay otra situación también
que pedro casi va a tener que hilar fino
porque él
digamos cumplir con las promesas que
hizo en campaña en las elecciones de
este año y que fueron apoyadas por mayor
medida por un 50 o mayor dicho una parte
de la población quien tiene que
responder a esos electores que lo han
llevado a la presidencia del perú pero
si él trata de cumplir los lineamientos
del partido perú libre que lo llevó al
poder dice en diversos analistas que va
a ser muy difícil para que haya una
gobernabilidad estable esto puede
generar nuevos enfrentamientos lo que ya
hemos visto en anteriores situaciones
tanto con pedro pablo kuczynski y más
que indicar